okay let's see if we can squeeze another
Colin let's go to the to10 area code
who's calling today from two one zero
which is a dangerous area code we've got
a lot of trolls in San Antonio okay
hello yeah hey um what's up David hey
you don't get it do you talk to you um I
don't know if you already been asked
about this I know you did a video and a
bunch of comments we're like kind of
freaking out on you but I just want to
get clarification on why you think
Andrew yang is anti-union
I mean you put a video up and then he
literally said I love unions yeah I just
have more leverage I misheard it and I
made a correction okay during the week I
completely miss her today so I gave an
analogy I was freaking out at Lee what
yeah yeah no I just I thought he said
I'm not a big fan of unions and he said
I'm a big fan of unions and I just
misheard it okay cool that's that makes
me feel so much better I didn't see that
correction I was like dude this is he's
always so on point and then he just
blatantly okay great and then I look one
last thing about hanging I was wondering
if you could explain a little bit of the
big differences in problems we had
between the Medicare for all and the
buy-in options talking about like the
singer pay pay pay but all the way
through or the Bryant I don't really
understand that I try to do it with
peace and love you're a bit confused
about Medicare Medicare buy-in
single-payer we're gonna lay out all of
the options soon it sort of exceeds the
scope of what I have time for right now
but my thing you know it you shouldn't
be choosing whether to pay for Medicare
it should just either everybody has
access because of the taxes that they
pay or they don't but the buy-in part I
I'm against and we'll talk more about it
in an upcoming segment Oh awesome whoa
again I'm really glad to hear that I was
corrected and yeah looking forward to
more stuff I really appreciate it
alright thank you so much appreciate the
call that does it for today sorry
everybody I couldn't get to but we will
take calls again maybe on an upcoming
live stream